c'est un soulagement pour les
commerçants et les clients
à moins d'un mois de noël les français
ont fait leur retour dans les magasins
pour réaliser leur premier achat depuis
l'instauration du deuxième confinement
vos sabres en amérique en deux mots je
suis très contente de pouvoir ressortir
c'est un bonheur de vous retrouver les
magasins ouverts c'est un bonheur de
faire attention
les mesures sont désormais allégé mardi
24 novembre
emmanuel macron a esquissé les grandes
lignes du plan de déconfinement détaillé
le lendemain par son premier ministre
jean castex la population peut se
déplacer durant trois heures dans un
rayon de 20 km contre une heure et 3 km
auparavant les commerces culturels et de
détail ont rouvert leurs portes et il
est désormais également possible de
sortir trois heures par jour pratiquer
une activité physique
la deuxième phase commencera le 15
décembre les données sanitaires seront
décisifs pour la suite eu des
confinement et les fêtes de fin d'année
si les français seront autorisés à se
déplacer pour cette période
un couvre-feu sera instauré de 21h à 7h
du matin excepté les 24 et 31 décembre
les salles de théâtre et de cinéma
pourront rouvrir enfin une troisième
phase sera amorcée le 20 janvier 2021
avec la réouverture des restaurants des
salles de sport et des lycées si le
nombre de cas d'infections kovy 19
passes en deçà des 5000 cas par jour
si les prévisions sanitaires sont
atteintes la france pour espérer se
rapprocher d'un déconfinement
généralisée comme le 11 mai dernier
toutefois la question des bars et des
discothèques restent elles en suspens